Lily I have to say has been crushing
these carpets can we talk about his
shocking shocking she's she's about to
turn 18 and she's just this she's a
perfect creature
well what's most amazing cuz it's all
happen very quickly for her it's just
boom she's so down-to-earth and she's so
sharp and sophisticated and treats it
with respect but doesn't take it all too
too serious to where it's a burden you
know she's I'm very proud of the way she
handles yourself I hear you're a bit of
a prankster one of your co-stars told me
that you put a dead fish in their dress
in their trailer oh yeah I've done worse
yeah you put you know some grilled
cheese in the heating duct turn on the
heater fragrant times and the pirate
sets it certainly there's a wake-up call
for the person who walks into that
trailer I have a fun shot Johnny Depp
quiz when we last spoke you said you and
Jack Sparrow of a lot of similarities
you guys have blended into one another a
little bit so I've got Jack or Johnny
okay
I have Jack or Johnny who is naughtier
I'm afraid Captain Jack did Jack okay
who is better at talking their way out
of escapade
Captain Jack who is the better sailor
captain Jill who is the biggest
prankster mate yeah who likes the run
better
Captain Jack the Captain Jack wins this
quiz basically to tie your shoes e Jack
Sparrow
for his advance a great planet does not
require such intricacies
[Music]
you